und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend und auch an einem heiteren
samstagabend müssen wir vom krieg
berichten der angriff auf den bahnhof
von caen motors gestern in der ost
ukraine sorgt auch am tag danach
international für entsetzen
mindestens 52 tote über 100 verletzte
der außenpolitische sprecher der eu
nennt den angriff auf zivilisten ein
kriegsverbrechen während aus dem osten
des landes weitere angriffe gemeldet
werden geht die untersuchung in den
kiefer vororten weiter dort wo die
russische armee abgezogen ist
beweissicherung damit die vielen
hinweise auf kriegsverbrechen später
auch vor gericht bestand haben katrin
eigendorf hatte gelegenheit in den
vorort ihre pin zu fahren hier ihr
bericht
die brücke die über den fluss ob ihnen
die gleichnamige stadt führt liegt in
trümmern aus den ausgebrannten autos
haben sie die leichen geborgen noch ist
nicht klar wie viele hier starben als
die russischen soldaten die menschen
beschossen die vor ihren panzern flohen
doch über die gleichen wackligen
holzbalken über die sie sich gerettet
hatten kehren jetzt die ersten zurück
wir waren nicht weit von hier ich bin
aus alpin wir haben dort unser haus ist
zerstört
kopien 25 kilometer von kiew entfernt
das war einmal stadtnahes wohnen in der
natur beliebt bei jungen familien die es
sich leisten konnten wir sind auf eigene
faust hierhin gekommen ohne begleitung
des innenministeriums juri der
kommandant der örtlichen
territorialverteidigung führt uns durch
das was geblieben ist ein trümmerfeld
wie butter wie baranka haben die
russischen soldaten auch ihn zu einem
ort des schreckens gemacht
juli zeigt uns wohnungen in denen sie
gehaust haben kinderzimmer geplündert
zerstört es sind kleinigkeiten die viel
erzählen über verrohung und gewalt gegen
zivilisten traurig fisch der soldat eine
konserve aus dem müll
russische armee ihre trocken gruppe so
haben sie hier gelebt sie haben
getrunken und sich amüsiert
und alkohol alles war hier auch alkohol
sie haben alle läden in der nähe
geplündert
auf der straße treffen wir zufällig eine
junge frau die sich mit ihrer
zehnjährigen tochter in einem keller
versteckt hatte weil ihre verwandten sie
vor den russischen soldaten gewarnt
hatten
sie haben frauen von den männern
getrennt und dann einige frauen weg
gebracht und verschiedene sachen mit
ihnen gemacht sie haben sie erschossen
vergewaltigt sagten meine verwandten
wirklich schreckliche dinge
vor einem hochhaus sitzen männer der
territorialverteidigung die die stadt
schützen sollen ein herrenloser hund ist
zum kameraden geworden im sechsten stock
führt julie uns durch die trümmer einer
wohnung
wir werden allen beweisen dass wir etwas
wert sind wir haben das schon bewiesen
werden es weiter tun denn wir haben den
besten präsidenten
sagt juri und wendet sich ab damit sich
seine tränen nicht sehe
zurück in kiew ist uns katrin eigendorf
jetzt zugeschaltet katrin nach dem
muster das wir schon kennen spricht die
russische regierung nun auch in ihre
bienen davon es handle sich um einen
medieninszenierung der ukraine um der
öffentlichkeit russische übergriffe
vorzuspielen sie waren vor ort gibt es
dafür irgendwelche hinweise
nein dafür gibt es keinen einzigen
hinweis den ich erlebt habe wir haben
uns ja extra die mühe gemacht nachdem
wir verschiedene orte gesehen haben nun
auch ihn uns anzugucken um einfach uns
ein gesamtbild machen zu können und an
keinem ort hat es irgendeinen hinweis
auf inszenierung gegeben und wir haben
uns hier auch die mühe gemacht auf
eigene faust los zu ziehen ohne
begleitung des innenministeriums wie das
an anderen orten der fall war wir
konnten selber mit leuten sprechen denen
wir auch teilweise per zufall auf der
straße begegnet sind und
was wir erlebt haben waren die gleichen
schilderung die wir zum beispiel auch in
butter gehört haben eben von wirklich
schlimmen übergriffen der russischen
armee auf zivilbevölkerung und die
menschen empfinden diesen vorwurf der
inszenierung darüber habe ich mit ihnen
auch gesprochen auch die soldaten der
territorialverteidigung damit
konfrontiert geradezu als verhöhnung in
diesem krieg der im prinzip all das
ganze noch einmal wie viel schlimmer
macht als es schon ist sie sagen ja sie
konnten sich in der vergangenen woche in
der tat ein umfassendes bild an mehreren
orten machen rund um kers jetzt
verlassen sie die ukraine für eine zeit
katrin welche eindrücke welche
erkenntnisse nehmen sie mit
also dass wir ja hier in der letzten
woche erlebt haben ist ein krieg wo wir
auf der einen seite schon sehen in welch
brutale maße geführt wird wo wir die
folgen sehen die schweren verbrechen die
russland hier an der zivilbevölkerung
begeht und auf der anderen seite wissen
wir dieser krieg wird weitergeführt an
anderer stelle ist ja nicht beendet ich
nehme einfach mit die befürchtung dass
wir noch viel viel grauen vollere bilder
erleben werden wenn eines tages einmal
städte wie mario pohl zum beispiel
befreit werden auf der anderen seite
beobachte ich auch auf westlicher seite
doch einen gewissen wandel in der
haltung man hat ja sehr lange ich glaube
bis butscher darauf gesetzt russland
durch sanktionen und gespräche dazu
bewegen zu können
diesen krieg zu stoppen man sieht
mittlerweile bei europäern bei
amerikanern schon lange dass
mittlerweile auch die westliche welt
darauf setzt dass sie die ukraine jetzt
bewaffnen muss damit das land diesen
krieg weiterführen kann also dass sich
anscheinend viele auch darauf einrichten
dass dieser krieg möglicherweise erst
einmal nur mit weiterem einsatz von
waffen für die ukraine zu gewinnen sein
muss die einschätzung von katrin
eigendorf gute rückreise und danke nach
kiew
ja und in der ukrainischen hauptstadt
mehren sich nun besucher der solidarität
gestern die eu kommissionspräsident in
oder von der leyen heute kam der
britische premier johnson nach kiew und
sagte militär und finanzhilfen zu auch
österreichs bundeskanzler neheimer
versprach präsident sie lenski
unterstützung unter anderem durch die
lieferung von rettungs- und
löschfahrzeugen ob mitglieder der
deutschen bundesregierung kurzfristig
besucher in kiew planen möglich aber
nicht bekannt deutschland steht der
ukraine zur seite das versicherte
bundeskanzler scholz heute in einer
videobotschaft an die internationale
geberkonferenz die in warschau stattfand
für die inzwischen fast viereinhalb
millionen flüchtlinge kamen am ende
insgesamt und zehn milliarden euro
zusammen natalie steger
in sicherheit und doch so viel
ungewissheit was kommt was den
angehörigen in der ukraine tod das
größte flüchtlingszentrum in polen nach
warschau irina ist attraktiv geflohen
mit enkel und zwei kinder
meine ältere tochter ist in der ukraine
geblieben sie ist 21 jahre alt sie hat
sich dort gemeldet um die ukraine zu
verteidigen
ich bin rechtzeitig raus gekommen
deshalb bin ich okay aber ich habe
freunde
immer in kontakt mit der heimat sind
ihre schicksale die von millionen die
die geberkonferenz in warschau in den
mittelpunkt rückt um die not der
flüchtlinge zu lindern ursula von der
leyen kommt direkt aus der ukraine
angereist und hat eine zusage der eu
kommission dabei eine milliarde euro für
flüchtlingshilfe
uns ist ganz wichtig dass wir auch geld
organisieren für diejenigen die
innerhalb der ukraine ihre heimat
verloren haben ihr haus verloren haben
zusammen gebaut worden sind und
verzweifelt hilfe suchen die
internationale geberkonferenz einberufen
von eu kommission kanada und der
organisation global citizen in warschau
weil polen die meisten geflüchteten
aufgenommen hat zahlreiche waren mit
dabei der präsident der ukraine mit
einer videobotschaft die
demokratische welt hat die macht zu
helfen überzeugen sie ihre politiker
bleiben sie bei der ukraine unterstützen
sie die freiheit unterstützen sie die
tapferkeit
eine weltweite social media kampagne
bringt 9,1 milliarden euro zusammen für
flüchtlingshilfe dazu kommt noch die
milliarde der eu kommission auch viele
prominente haben die aktion unterstützt
wie celine dion madonna billy eilig
julian lennon mit dem song seines vaters
imagine für eine friedliche welt
[Musik]
wer will
und nun zunächst ins inland die
nachrichten mit gundula gause die
rheinland pfälzische ministerpräsident
in drei er hat in der flut nach des
vergangenen juli auf den
katastrophenschutz im aartal vertraut im
untersuchungsausschuss des landtages
erklärte sie sie habe am 14 juli bis zum
späten abend keinen hinweis gehabt dass
es zu einer solchen nie dagewesenen
flutkatastrophe kommen würde bei der
sturzflut durch das urteil waren 134
menschen ums leben gekommen
die spd hat mit empörung auf einen
bericht reagiert wonach der cdu
politiker konrad adenauer als
bundeskanzler die spd spitze fast zehn
jahre lang ausspionieren ließ laut
süddeutscher zeitung lieferte ein
spitzel des bundesnachrichtendienstes
von 1953 bis 63 informationen aus der
spd-spitze an adenauer
spd-generalsekretär kühnert kritisiert
dies als
skrupellosen machtmissbrauch und fordert
die cdu zu kritische aufarbeitung auf
in pakistan hat das parlament
premierminister kan das vertrauen
entzogen nach tagelangem machtkampf
stimmte die opposition gemeinsam mit
abweichlern aus kans eigener partei
dafür ihn des amtes zu entheben unter
anderem linke und religiöse hardliner
wollen nun gemeinsam eine neue regierung
bilden
ministerpräsident der atommacht soll der
chef der pakistanischen
muslim-liga werden
die zeitenwende in der wir uns nach dem
angriff russlands auf die ukraine
befinden hat der bundeswehr ein
sogenanntes sondervermögen verschafft
von 100 milliarden euro es wird über die
ausstattung gesprochen die eine moderne
schlagkräftige truppe haben muss aber
längst auch über ihren auftrag
auslandsmissionen dienten wie in
afghanistan machen jedenfalls keinen
sinn wie sinnvoll ist noch der einsatz
in mali rund 1300 bundeswehrsoldaten
sind in dem westafrikanischen land
stationiert stabilisierung und
ausbildung ihr auftrag
der einsatz erscheint zunehmend
fragwürdig auch der
bundesverteidigungsministerium die mali
derzeit besucht ines trams begleitet sie
ankunft in gau im norden malis die
verteidigungsministerium besucht die
deutschen soldaten die hier mit der
un-mission minustah das land
stabilisieren wollen die zukunft des
mandats offen denn die franzosen ziehen
ab vollends erstritten mit der malischen
runter und ihre kampfhubschrauber nehmen
sie mit es fehlt nun der schutz aus der
luft wir können nicht die lücke
schließen in bezug auf den einsatz von
kampfhubschraubern um diesen schutz zu
gewährleisten und wir können auch nicht
diesen flugplatz hier betreiben das
heißt da gibt es viel zu tun und das
muss geklärt werden bevor es da zu einer
entscheidung kommen kann deutsche
ministerin und un suchen derzeit nach
einem partner der den schutz aus der
luft übernehmen kann die opposition
fordert deutschland müsse bleiben in
mali mit einem robusteren mandat
wir wollen hier keinen terror kampf
betreiben aber die truppe muss in der
lage sein sich selbst verteidigen zu
können wenn sie denn angegriffen wird
und hier haben andere nationen mehr
möglichkeiten die soldaten berichten der
ministerin ihre aufgabe hier in der
sahel zone sei wichtig bei einem abzug
hätte mali kaum eine chance mit folgen
auch für deutschland dadurch dass hier
eine stabilität hergestellt wird
terrorismus eingedämmt wird als eine
mögliche flucht ursache er ist - mal
deswegen für die zone eine wertvolle
operationen optionen mali bislang nicht
befriedet terror gebiet militäroffizier
azemi gotha putscht sich an die macht
wahlen will er erstmal nicht abhalten im
kampf gegen den terror verlässt er sich
zusehends auf russische söldner der
gruppe wagner brutal gehen sie mit der
malische armee gegen terroristen und
zivilisten vor auf der kippe
entsprechend die trainings mission der
eu soldaten für die hunde ausbilden das
will die ministerin nicht der unsere
soldaten und soldaten bilden top aus
aber dann geht diese soldaten in den
einsatz mit russischen kräften womöglich
mit söldnern womöglich werden
verbrechen menschenrechtsverletzungen
begangen dann widerspricht das unseren
werten und dann habt sich auch für
dieses mandat keine zukunft im mai
stehen beide mandate zur verlängerung an
dann muss der bundestag entscheiden in
afrika bleiben oder abziehen
und nun nochmal nachrichten gundela
der schauspieler uwe bohm ist im alter
von 60 jahren gestorben
nach angaben seiner familie plötzlich
und unerwartet von schauspieler hark
bohm adoptiert begann er schon als kind
mit der schauspielerei es folgten
dutzende filme vor allem krimis in denen
er oft den bösewicht gab dazu feierte
uwe bohm über jahrzehnte große
theatererfolge
die gewinnzahlen vom lotto lauten ohne
gewähr 5 17 27 33 43 45 superzahl 6
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
nach diesem typischen april wochenende
wird das wetter wieder freundlicher im
südwesten morgen viel sonne und meist
trocken sonst ein mix aus sonne und
wolken regen schnee und graupelschauern
lebhafter nordwestwind 4 bis 13 grad in
den nächsten tagen gibt es mehr sonne
und es wird wärmer am mittwoch 14 bis 23
grad
das lässt doch hoffen so und jetzt
direkt weiter zum sportstudio wo jochen
breyer sie erwartet gemeinsam mit dem
neuen dfb präsidenten bernd neuendorf
und danach um 00 55 gibt es wieder eine
heute express bis morgen
[Musik]